Hey les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux,
Il faut que je vous raconte quelque chose.
J'ai rêvé que je recevais le père Noël
dans mon atelier.
J'étais installé dans mon fauteuil, en train de lire
des contes de Noël
et puis je me suis endormi.
Et là...
c'est parti.
- Hey oh monsieur !
Vous vous en sortez avec tout ce courrier ?
- Oui, je commence à avoir l'habitude
mais je ferais bien une petite pause.
- Ça tombe bien.
Allez, suivez-moi !
Qu'est-ce que je vous sers ?
Thé ou café ?
- Mettez-moi un café, tiens !
Les gens sont persuadés
que je ne bois que du soda.
Hé, il faut que je garde la ligne, moi,
pour passer dans les cheminées.
- Voilà, attention, c'est chaud.
Alors, comment je dois vous appeler ?
Monsieur Noël ?
Père Noël ?
Pas frère Noël quand même ?
- Un peu comme vous voulez,
en général c'est père Noël ou Santa Claus.
Ça dépend de l'endroit où je suis.
Vous le savez, je voyage beaucoup, hein.
Alors ici, c'est père Noël.
Là-bas, c'est Santa Claus.
- Il y a une question
que tout le monde se pose.
Elle est un peu indiscrète,
mais bon, allez, j'ose.
Quel âge avez-vous ?
- Je suis embêté.
Je suis incapable de vous répondre.
Figurez-vous que j'ai perdu mes papiers
lors d'une livraison.
D'ailleurs, si quelqu'un tombe dessus,
surtout qu'il n'hésite
pas à se manifester.
Mais bon, j'ai quand même l'impression
d'avoir toujours été là.
- En tout cas, quel que soit votre âge,
vraiment, chapeau parce que
vous avez la forme.
- Ah, ça c'est gentil Jamy.
Mais faut dire que je fais
beaucoup d'exercice.
- Et qu'est-ce que vous faites
en particulier ?
- La rennitation.
- De la quoi ?
- La rennitation ! Vous savez, quand on grimpe
à califourchon sur un renne et qu'on galope.
Vous faites ça avec les chevaux,
vous appelez ça l'équitation.
Moi, je fais de la rennitation
et puis aussi de l'escalade.
Il faut s'entraîner
pour grimper aux cheminées.
- Bien père Noël, j'ai remarqué
que vous étiez un peu de la vieille école
au niveau du courrier,
vous ne traitez que du courrier manuscrit.
Mais puisque c'est Noël,
j'ai envie de vous faire un petit cadeau.
Je vais vous prêter mon atelier
et vous allez pouvoir faire
votre premier tuto pour YouTube,
dans lequel vous allez expliquer
comment on rédige
une belle lettre au père Noël.
- C'est gentil, je veux bien essayer,
mais c'est une première pour moi.
Bienvenue sur ma chaîne YouTube.
Si vous avez été sages cette année,
et même si vous avez fait
quelques petites bêtises,
vous pouvez avoir des cadeaux.
Pour cela, il faut m'écrire.
Aujourd'hui, voici un tuto pour vous apprendre
à écrire une belle lettre au père Noël.
Si vous aimez cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner.
Pour ce tuto, il vous faut une feuille
de papier à lettre, un stylo et une enveloppe.
Vous commencez par l'en-tête :
"Cher papa Noël" ou "Cher père Noël".
Puis, vous établissez
la liste de vos souhaits
que j'exaucerai en fonction
des stocks disponibles.
Vous pliez ensuite la lettre en trois
et vous la glissez dans l'enveloppe.
Pas besoin de timbre, vous inscrivez juste père Noël,
puis vous la postez.
N'oubliez pas
d'indiquer votre adresse au dos.
Il faut que je sache où
déposer vos cadeaux.
Voilà.
Maintenant, vous savez comment rédiger
une lettre au père Noël.
A très bientôt sur ma chaîne YouTube.
- Père Noël, il faut pas oublier
la photo aussi, hein, pour la vignette.
- Photo.
- Alors là, bravo père Noël,
vraiment,
vous vous débrouillez très,
très bien pour un débutant.
Alors il y a quand même
un grand mystère avec vous.
Comment faites-vous pour livrer
tous ces cadeaux en 24 heures ?
- Ce n'est pas très compliqué,
je vais vous expliquer.
Et puis, je ruse un petit peu.
D'abord, il faut savoir qu'à un instant T,
il n'est pas la même heure
partout sur la planète.
Tenez, par exemple,
quand il est midi ici dans l'atelier,
eh bien, il est 6 heures du matin à New York
et 17 heures à Bombay, en Inde.
Et c'est normal !
Parce que ces endroits ne sont pas
éclairés en même temps par le Soleil.
Alors, pour repérer ce décalage
et pour que partout où l'on soit
on sache quelle heure il est ailleurs,
eh bien, les géographes ont dessiné
ce que l'on appelle des fuseaux horaires.
Vous savez, ces espèces de lignes
verticales que l'on voit sur les cartes.
Il y en a 24 qui correspondent
aux 24 heures de la journée.
Eh bien, je profite de ce décalage
horaire.
Je commence ma tournée
en Nouvelle-Zélande.
C'est l'endroit où on passe en premier
du 24 décembre au 25 décembre.
Je démarre donc ma tournée
le 25 décembre à zéro heure et je vais très vite !
En 60 minutes, je parcours
la totalité du fuseau horaire.
Faut pas chômer, hein !
Quand j'ai fini ma tournée
sur ce fuseau,
il est 1 heure du matin en Nouvelle-Zélande
mais zéro heure sur le fuseau d'à côté,
le fuseau qui précède.
Donc du coup, je demande à mes rennes
de se décaler vers l'ouest et je recommence.
1 heure plus tard quand je finis ma tournée
sur ce nouveau fuseau,
Il est 1 heure à l'endroit où je suis
mais zéro heure sur le fuseau suivant.
Etc. Etc.
Et je continue comme ça
jusqu'au 24ᵉ fuseau horaire.
Donc j'ai au moins 24 heures pour faire ma tournée.
En fait pour tout vous dire,
j'ai même un peu plus de temps.
Ben oui, quand je termine ma tournée,
il est 1 heure du matin.
Mais à 1 heure du matin, les enfants dorment,
ils dorment au moins jusqu'à 7 heures.
Donc, j'ai un petit rab de 6 heures
pour finir ma tournée.
Au total, ça me fait donc une trentaine
d'heures pour distribuer tous mes cadeaux.
Franchement, c'est du sport,
mais avec une bonne organisation
et des rennes bien entraînés, ça le fait.
Au passage, je voudrais remercier
tous ceux qui me laissent un petit verre de lait
et quelques friandises
au pied de la cheminée.
Ça fait du bien.
- Merci père Noël
pour toutes ces explications.
Bon, quand même,
votre job est un peu dangereux.
Et puis, tout n'est pas légal
dans ce que vous faites.
J'ai retrouvé un article publié
dans Le Monde en 2019
qui dresse la liste des infractions.
Alors, j'ai pris quelques notes parce que,
effectivement, la liste est un peu longue.
D'abord, pour livrer vos cadeaux,
vous pénétrez dans des propriétés privées,
vous êtes d'accord !?
Or, c'est totalement interdit.
Rien que pour la France,
ça représente 29 millions de foyers.
Vous risquez déjà un an de prison
et 15000€ d'amende.
Allez, deuxième délit la contrebande.
Eh oui, vous importez des tonnes de
marchandises sans déclaration douanière.
Et là, c'est plus salé, 11 ans de prison
et 75000€ d'amende.
Je continue, le survol des zones
interdites à bord de votre traineau.
Bon, j'arrête là.
Mais si on cumule toutes ces infractions,
ça fait quand même
un total de 21 millions d'euros
d'amende et 31 ans de prison.
Vous vous rendez compte père Noël !?
31 ans de prison !
Alors je sais que vous pouvez vivre vieux
mais quand même.
- Je bénéficie d'une certaine immunité,
mon cher Jamy.
Il faut dire quand même
que je participe au bonheur des enfants.
- C'est vrai que vous faites
le plus beau métier du monde.
Vous distribuez des cadeaux aux enfants.
Comment vous est venue cette vocation ?
C'est une très longue histoire
mais je vais essayer de faire court.
Ça a commencé avec un ancêtre
au Moyen Âge, Saint-Nicolas.
Il passait dans les familles
un soir de décembre,
distribuait des cadeaux
aux enfants sages.
Et puis, avec le temps,
Saint-Nicolas est devenu Sinterklaas.
Santa Claus.
Des noms en fonction des époques
et des endroits où on se trouvait.
Mais le principe était toujours le même :
distribuer des cadeaux en décembre
pour rendre les petits
et les grands heureux.
- Mais depuis quand exercez-vous ?
- Aussi loin que je m'en souvienne,
j'ai toujours fait ça, alors j'ai du mal
à vous dire quand j'ai commencé
précisément.
J'ai eu un petit accident,
un jour ou une nuit, lors d'une tournée,
un refus de priorité par un renne.
Bref, le traîneau a chaviré
et j'ai perdu tous mes papiers.
Pièce d'identité, carte Vitale,
document d'Urssaf...
J'ai même pas une facture d'électricité.
Donc, du coup, j'ai bien du mal à
vous dire quand précisément j'ai commencé.
Mais en fouillant dans mes archives,
j'ai retrouvé un document,
un vieux document, un poème.
- Oui, d'ailleurs, nous l'avons, ce poème.
Il a été écrit en 1823 par Clément Moore,
un Américain qui l'a écrit pour distraire
ses enfants le soir de Noël.
Et puis, apparemment,
ce poème a été envoyé par les voisins
ou les voisines de Clément Moore
à la presse.
Et ce poème a presque été publié par erreur
et c'est comme ça
qu'est née la légende du père Noël,
dans laquelle vous vous êtes engouffré.
- Comme quoi, voyez-vous, la célébrité
ça tient parfois à un fil.
- Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi vous êtes habillé en rouge ?
On dit souvent que c'est
un fabricant de sodas
qui vous aurait contraint
à adopter cette couleur.
- C'est beaucoup plus vieux que ça.
Ça date de 1863, un dessinateur américain
m’a campé dans un costume rouge
et à partir de ce moment-là,
ma garde robe est devenue rouge.
- En tout cas, ça vous va très bien père Noël.
- Arrêtez Jamy !
Vous allez me faire rougir.
- Alors, un autre grand mystère qui vous
concerne père Noël, c'est votre adresse.
Où habitez-vous ?
- Ça mon cher Jamy, c’est tenu secret.
Peut-être en France,
en Finlande ou au pôle Nord.
- Allez, père Noël,
un petit effort !
Dites-nous vraiment où vous habitez.
Ça, ce serait vraiment un super cadeau.
- Personne ne nous écoute !?
Alors, c'est simple.
En sortant d'ici, vous partez à droite,
vous allez tout droit pendant 200 km ...
- Hé dis donc, c’est à vous
le traineau devant en double file !?
J'ai rêvé ou pas !?
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
qu'elle vous a fait rêver.
Je vous souhaite un très joyeux Noël,
de la douceur, de la tendresse,
de la bienveillance
et d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
à toutes et à tous.